FRAUD.
WE WILL PLAY AT NIGHT ON
"HANNITY," BUT ON THE EVE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE WITH JUST 36
DAYS AWAY FROM WHAT I BELIEVE BY
FAR IS THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
ELECTION AND OUR LIFETIME, WELL,
THE TIME FOR URGENCY AND ALL
HANDS ON DECK IS RIGHT NOW.
I’VE SAID MANY, MANY TIMES,
ELECTIONS YOU NEED TO TAKE
NOTHING FOR GRANTED AND IF YOU
HAVEN’T REGISTERED TO VOTE,
GUESS WHAT, I HAVE A SPECIAL
PART OF MY WEBSITE,
Hannity.com, INFORMATION HOW DO
YOU REGISTER, WHAT DOES VOTING
START IN YOUR STATE, WHO’S
RUNNING THROUGH THE
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT?
YOU HAVE A SENATE RACE THIS
YEAR.
WHEN HIS EARLY VOTING STARTS AND
WHEN DOES IT STOP AND WHAT ABOUT
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE ABSENTEE
THIS YEAR?
ALL THE INFORMATION YOU COULD
WANT.
GO TO THE POLLS AND EXERCISE
THIS INCREDIBLE GOD-GIVEN RIGHT.
A LOT IS LITERALLY HANGING IN
THE BALANCE.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT OUR KIDS IN
THE FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY, YOU
MUST DO YOUR PART.
EVERY MAJOR INSTITUTIONAL FORCE
IN THIS COUNTRY, IN THE D.C.
SWAMP, AND THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA, THE 99.9% OF STATE RUN
NEWSPAPERS, STATE RUN
BROADCASTS, STATE RUN CABLE, ARE
COMPLETELY INVESTED IN DEFEATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS THEY HAVE
BEEN -- WELL, FROM THE SECOND HE
COME DOWN THE ESCALATOR WITH
MELANIA TRUMP.
OF THE STAKES HAVE NEVER BEEN
HIGHER.
WE LOOK AT THE WE DESERVE.
JOE’S POLICIES ARE THE MOST
RADICAL, OUT OF THE MAINSTREAM
OF ANY MAJOR POLITICAL PARTY
NOMINEE IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IT RADICAL SOCIALISM, HIGHER AND
HIGHER TAXES REDISTRIBUTION
ELIMINATING THE FOSSIL FUELS,
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO BECOME THE UNITED
CENTURY STATES OF THE
AMERICA AND BY THE WAY, FOREIGN
POLICY APPEASEMENT.
THEY MIGHT GET $150 BILLION AND
NOTHING FOR IT.
THIS ENTIRE CAMPAIGN JOE BIDEN
AND HIS CAMPAIGN HAVE BEEN
HIDING FROM YOU, WE COME IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF JOE BIDEN ALMOST NEVER TAKES
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS AND
WHEN HE DOES THE REPORTERS ARE
PRESELECTED BY MEMBERS OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
IT TODAY, HE OFFICIALLY RETIRED
TO HIS BASEMENT AND A WHOPPING
9:52:00 A.M. WHICH MARKS THE
11TH TIME THAT JUST IN THIS
MONTHS OF SEPTEMBER, THAT THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN PUT A LEAD ON ANY
MORE EVENTS BEFORE NOON.
THIS IS NOT NORMAL.
THEY ARE CLEARLY TRYING TO HIDE
THINGS FROM WE, THE PEOPLE.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE CALL IT A
DAY BEFORE TEN A AT 10:00 A.M.,
WEEKEND AND WEEK OUT FOR MONTHS.
JUST WEEKS AWAY, 36 DAYS UNTIL A
VERY IMPORTANT PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
MEANWHILE, RUNNING MATES,
SENATOR, LA HARRIS MADE A RARE
PUBLIC APPEARANCE HERSELF TODAY.
NATURALLY, SHE RACED OFF STAGE
BEFORE TAKING QUESTIONS FROM THE
PRESS.
ZERO TRANSPARENCY FROM PEOPLE
RUNNING FOR THE HIGHEST OFFICE
IN THE LAND.
THEIR FRIENDS, THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY COVER IT AND THEY ARE THE
GREAT ENABLERS, THE GREAT
SUPPORTERS IN THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTORS TO DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM.
THANKFULLY TOMORROW, WE MIGHT
ACTUALLY GET A CHANCE TO HEAR
FROM JOE ON SEVERAL IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT HE IS HEREE TO REFUS
TO ADDRESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, JOE, DO YOU SUPPORT
PACKING THE SUPREME COURT BEING
THREATENED BY LEADERS OF YOUR
PARTY.
WHAT JUDGE WOULD YOU APPOINT TO
THE HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND IF
THERE IS A VACANCY WHEN YOU
WHERE PRESIDENT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, HE
PUBLISHED THE LONG LIST OF
PROSPECTIVE JUDGES.
IS HE GETTING RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND WHY DID
JOE BIDEN’S RUNNING MATE
PROMOTES A FOND OF THAT BUILD UP
VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND RIOTERS
OUT OF JAIL?
WHITED, LE WHY DID YOU SAY POLIC
BECOME THE ENEMY?
WHY DID YOU SUPPORT
REALLOCATING, JUST A WAY OF
SAYING DEFUNDING FUNDS AWAY FROM
THE POLICE?
WHY THE SILENCE AS THE NATION
WATCHED NIGHT AFTER NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT, LOOTING, ASSAULT, BEND AS
ZONE, HIJACKING IN TAKING OVER
OR GROUND DEMAND BURNING TO THE
GROUND POLICE PRECINCTS.
ALL THAT’S HAPPENED THAT ROCKED
THE COUNTRY TO THE CORE ALL
SUMMER LONG.
DID NOT MENTION IT AT YOUR OWN
CONVENTION.
WHEN YOU WERE VICE PRESIDENT,
THERE’S 4,000 HOMICIDES IN YOUR
HOMETOWN, 20,000 SHOOTINGS.
YOU DID NOTHING AND YOU BARELY
MENTIONED IT.
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTING GUN
CONFISCATING EFFORTS.
YEAH, WERE COMING FOR YOUR A
CASE.
OR KAMALA HARRIS BELIEVES, WELL,
SHE COULD DO IT BY EXECUTIVE
FIAT.
WILL YOU SUPPORT THAT OR SUPPORT
YOUR ZERO EXPERIENCE SANS HUNTER
HUNTER?
AND HIS SKETCHY OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALS WITH THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA?
WE LEARNED LAST WEEK SHOPPING
SPREES COURTESY OF CHINA.
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS, UKRAINIAN
OLIGARCHS.
WIRE TRANSFERS.
ALL BACK AND FORTH AND NOW IT’S
ALL OUT THERE.
IT TAKE A LOOK, JOE, DO YOU
SUPPORT THAT?
WILL YOU SAY THAT YOU DIDN’T
KNOW ANYTHING?
YOU DIDN’T LEVERAGE $1 BILLION
TO GET A PROSECUTOR TO GET HIM
FIRED?
WHY YOUR SON ADMITS ON
"GOOD MORNING AMERICA" ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN OIL, GAS, ENERGY
TRADE.
WHY DID THEY GIVE HIM MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS?
WHO KNOWS, MAYBE BECAUSE YOU ARE
THE VICE PRESIDENT, JOE.
YOU FORCIBLY PLACE THE COUNTRY
ON ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN
AND WHERE DO YOU STAND ON
MANDATORY MASKS BECAUSE YOU FLIP
AND FLOP, FLOP, FLIP, FLAIL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
ANSWERS TO ALL OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
HERE’S WHAT I BELIEVE -- THIS IS
MY OPINION, THE OPINION PART OF
THE SHOW.
IT HAS BEEN HAPPENING BEHIND THE
SCENES THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN THE
WHOLE SUMMER, I BELIEVE THAT HIS
CAMPAIGN TEAM THEY ARE SEEING
WHAT WE SEE.
THEY SAY THAT JOE BIDEN IS WEAK
AND THAT HE IS FRAIL.
THAT HE IS STRUGGLING
COGNITIVELY.
HIS STAFF, THEY MADE A CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO HIDE HIM.
THE CORRUPT MEDIA MOB OF THE
COUNTRY ALLOWED HIM AND THEM TO
GET AWAY WITH ALL OF THIS.
SO, JOE BIDEN, HE PROBABLY SPENT
PRETTY MUCH HOURS EVERY SINGLE
DAY ALL SUMMER LONG WITH FOUR OR
FIVE POINTS THAT HE MEMORIZES ON
EVERY LIKELY ISSUE THAT WILL
COME UP DURING THE DEBATE AND
PROBABLY ONE OR TWO SCRIPTED
ATTACK LINES AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
IN BETWEEN, OF COURSE, PLENTY
SCHEDULED HOT COCOA BREAKS AND
NAPS OF COURSE.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN FELT IT WAS TOO RISKY
TO POINT THEM OUT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL SO THEY PUT ALL
THEIR EGGS IN THE DEBATE BASKET
AND WE WILL SEE FOR THE FIRST
TIME TOMORROW HOW WELL THE
STRATEGY OF STUDYING ALL SUMMER
LONG HAS WORKED OUT.
TOMORROW, I SUSPECT THAT ALL
THOSE MONTHS OF PREPARATION, IT
WILL BE SOMEWHAT EFFECTIVE AND
YOU SURVIVE THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY DEBATES, BUT HIS STAFF,
THE DEMOCRATS, I CAN TELL YOU
FOR A FACT THAT THEY ARE
TERRIFIED ABOUT THAT THESE THREE
DEBATES.
WE KNOW JOE WILL LIKELY TAKE ON
THE SAME TONE, CADENCE, PITCH
THAT HE TOOK OUT WITH HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE ON FAKE NEW CNN WITH
ANDERSON COOPER.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DELIVER HIS
CAREFULLY WORDED SCRIPTED THAT
THEY’VE BEEN PRACTICING ALL
SUMMER.
EVEN HIS STAFF KNOWS HOW FRAGILE
HE IS.
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST TERRIFIED OF
LETTING THEIR OWN CANDIDATES
SPEAK OFF-THE-CUFF AND FRANKLY,
THEY SHOULD BE AND FOR PLENTY OF
GOOD REASON.
OVER THE WEEKEND, JOE COULD NOT
SEEM TO GET ANYTHING STRAIGHT
AND DID YOU KNOW THAT HE WAS IN
THE U.S. SENATE, WELL, FOR THE
FIRST TIME 180 YEARS AGO?
LIKE IT, 200 MILLION DEAD FROM
COVID-19.
LIKE HE FORGOT THAT HE OPPOSED
THE TRAVEL BAN.
LIKE ENDOWED BY THE OH, YOU
KNOW, THE THING, OH, YOU’LL
KNOW, THE THING.
GOD APPEARED AND DOUBTED BY THE
CREATOR, GOD, THE CREATOR OF
EVERYTHING.
MIXING UP THE SUPER THURSDAY OR
MIXING UP THE STATES THAT HE’S
IN ANY GIVEN MOMENT.
OR RUNNING FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
>> I MADE A PRIORITY IN MY
CAREER TO WORK CLOSELY WITH YOU
AND BY THE TIME I GOT TO THE
SENATE 180 YEARS AGO.
I SUPPOSE MY TENURE AS
VICE PRESIDENT.
I WOULD MAKE THIS COMMITMENT TO
YOU.
YOU WILL HAVE AN ACCESS DIRECTLY
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
I’M GOING TO BE RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
>> Sean: 180 YEARS AGO, JOE,
REALLY?
ACTUALLY, THAT’S PROBABLY THE
CLOSEST HE GOT TO AN HONEST
STATEMENT ALL CAMPAIGN.
HIS STRUGGLES DID NOT END THERE
DURING A VERY FRIENDLY INTERVIEW
ON MSDNC, THE CONSPIRACY
NETWORK CHANNEL, WATCH AS THE HA
TO PAINFULLY STAB IN AND LIFT
THEM OUT OF TROUBLE.
HELP JOE REMEMBER HIS OWN
TALKING POINTS.
THIS IS HOW CORRUPT THE MOB IS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> 1% OF THE MONEY HAS GONE OUT.
1%.
1% OF THE DASH THAT’S NOT THE
PAYCHECK, THE, THE BILL FOR
MAJOR --
>> MAY SAVE MONEY.
>> THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PACKAGE WENT OUT AND YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
BUSINESSES UNDER 15 EMPLOYEES.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW
OH, OH, NOBODY IS HERE TO HELP
ME.
BY THE WAY, THAT THE GUY YOU
WANT REPRESENTING US ON THE
WORLD STAGE IN THIS COUNTRY?
YOU THINK PRESIDENT PUTIN THINK
THAT THEY’RE GOING TO EAT THIS
GUY ALIVE?
DO YOUWOW, YOU THINK HE’S CAPABL
LEADING THE FREE WORLD?
I DON’T.
TOMORROW IS THEATER FOR JOE.
JOE WILL BE REGURGITATING HIS
MEMORYMEMORIZED ATTACK LINES.
REENTERING FIVE DIFFERENT WAYS
TO GET THROUGH THE TWO MINUTE
ANSWER, THE 92ND ANSWER.
BY THE WAY, HE HAD THE ENTIRE
SUMMER TO PRACTICE AND WHO KNOWS
WHO’S GOING T TO SHOW UP TOMORRO
YOU HAVE TO VOTE FOR HIM BECAUSE
NAZI GERMANY AND FIDEL CASTRO.
TO LISTEN TO THIS VICIOUS
ATTACK.
>> I’M NOT SURE ANYBODY HAD
ALREADY MADE IT, BUT
HE’S LIKE JOSEPH GOEBBELS.
IF YOU KEEP IT SAYING THE LINE,
IT BECOMES, KNOWLEDGE.
PEOPLE SEE VERY CLEARLY BETWEEN
ME AND DONALD TRUMP.
TRUMP, TRUMP’S CLEARING PROTESTS
IN FRONT OF THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
ARE PEACEFUL.
WITH THE MILITARY.
AT THIS GUYS MORE CASTRO THAN
CHURCHILL.
>> Sean: REALLY?
JOE BIDEN COMPARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE WORLD’S
TWO MOST TERRIBLE MONSTERS.
HE INFORMED THE MEDIA MOB THAT
NO ONE IS ALLOWED TO ATTACK JOE
FOR HIS GAFFES.
I GUESS I MISSED THE MEMO
BECAUSE WE’RE JUST CALLING IT
LIKE WE SEE IT AND SHOWING YOU
THE TRUTH SO YOU CAN DECIDE.
I TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOUR HUSBAND HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO MAKE THE OCCASIONAL GAFFE.
>> OH, YOU CAN’T EVEN GO THERE,
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU
CANNOT EVEN SAY THE WORD TO
GAFFE.
>> I CAN’T SAY THE WORD GAFFE?
>> NO COME ON DOWN.
IT’S GONE.
>>SPEAK OF THE GAFFE ISSUE IS
OVER.
SO OVER.
>> Sean: SO OVER!
I’VE BEEN IN THE SENATE 100 AND
YEARS.
HARD-HITTING JOURNALISM AND FAKE
NEW CNN.
REAL JOURNALISTS MIGHT BE
SEEMINGLY MORE CONCERNED WITH
THE SO-CALLED GAFFES AND HIS
NUMBERS TO MY TROUBLES WITH
NUMBERS, REMEMBERING THE DAYS OF
THE WEEK, THE OFFICE IS RUNNING
FOR, AND THE EXTREMELY LIGHT
CAMPAIGN SCHEDULE, AND THE
COMPLETE BLACKOUT OF THE MEDIA.
HE WON’T ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND MORE TROUBLES BY THE WAY,
TROUBLING JOE’S TROUBLE WITH THE
GROUP AND HE LIED ABOUT HIS
GRADES IN SCHOOL AND LIED ABOUT
HAVING 3 DEGREES FROM COLLEGE.
LIED ABOUT GETTING A FULL RIDE
FROM LAW SCHOOL AND WHERE HE
CAME IN HIS CLASS IN TERMS OF
GRADUATING.
IT LIED ABOUT GETTING ARRESTED
IN THE APARTHEID SOUTH AFRICA
AND ON HIS WAY TO VISIT
NELSON MANDELA AND LIED ABOUT
MARCHING IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT IN 1960s, BUT HE
PRAYS THE FORMER KLANSMAN
THAT FILIBUSTERED THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AGAINST THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF THAN HE DID.
HE PARTNERED WITH THE FARMER
CLANSMEN AND WHY, BECAUSE HE DID
NOT WANT INTEGRATION OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BECAUSE HE DIDN’T
WANT HIS KIDS GOING TO TO THE
SCHOOLS WERE RACIAL JUNGLES.
HE ATTENDED A WERE HISTORICALLY
BLACK UNIVERSITY, ANOTHER
WHOPPER.
>> HBCUS.
I GOT STARTED OUT OF THERE.
AT DELAWARE STATE.
IF I DON’T WANT TO HEAR ANYTHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT DELAWARE STATE
HERE, OKAY?
THEY ARE MY FOLKS.
>> Sean: PROBLEM IS
DELAWARE STATE UNIVERSITY DENIED
THAT JOE WAS EVER A STUDENT AT
THE HISTORICALLY BLACK
UNIVERSITY.
INSTEAD OF ATTENDING, THE SCHOOL
JOE GOT HIS START, WELL, THE
U.S. SENATE TO WORKING WITH THE
SEGREGATIONISTS TO STOP
INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS.
ACCORDING TO JOE, DID NOT WANT
THE KIDS, GROWING UP IN THE
RACIAL JUNGLE.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN HAS BEEN ON
THE PHONE FOR NEARLY 50 YEARS
WHERE LYING IS JUST A WAY OF
LIFE.
IT DID I HIS PLAGIARISM QUIZ
THEM?HE WILL DO OR SAY ANYTHING
VOTE AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, HE HAS NOT ACCOMPLISHED
HARDLY ANYTHING AND NOTHING I
CAN THINK OF THAT HAS BENEFITED
THE PEOPLE IN 47 YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP LIKES TO SAY ALL
TALK, ALL TALK, ALL PROMISES,
NEW PROMISES.
HOW DID THE OBAMACARE PROMISES
WORK OUT?
WORST OF ALL, HE’S CONTROLLED BY
THE RADICAL BASE OF HIS PARTY
AND THEY’RE BRAGGING ABOUT
CONTROLLING HIM LIKE A OC.
IF ELECTED, THEY’LL CARRY HIS
BIDDING AND SUCCESSFUL THEY WILL
RIP THE COUNTRY OF HARD TO AND
THE GATE TO THE VERY FREEDOMS
THAT WE HAVE ENJOYED FOR ENTIRE
HISTORY.